here we do see the final
final stages Peter of this game
and also breaking news for the
tournament Prague is bouncing back he is
not going home he is heading towards the
play of Tomorrow against Argent argoshi
and that will be an incredible fight
and there we go it's a handshake Black
second Queen appears on the board and
Eric icy resigns we're in for more chess
tomorrow guaranteed between these two
young superstars
practicus Johnson here we see the
drawing of lots they're choosing colors
uh the Arbiter I was there a few days
ago the Arbiter does always offer up the
pawns so that they can pick and I'm not
sure which one era guys he got there